today is deadline day for the franchise
tag application nobody was messing
around yesterday it's like hey we're
back from the combine we're not taking
any chances let's go ahead and apply
these tags and there were a rash of tags
applied on monday five in all to go with
the one that already was applied last
week to kicker robbie gold five
defensive lineman slash linebackers is
going to be a fight i think between a
couple of these guys and their teams
regarding whether they're defensive ends
which is a higher franchise tender or
linebackers which is lower but demarcus
lawrence davian clowney grady jarrett
frank clark d ford all tagged on monday
and chris it's no surprise because the
hierarchy in the nfl is quarterback
pass rusher yeah the two most important
positions on the field and when you have
a good pass rusher you don't let him hit
the open market no you don't let them
hit the open market or if they have the
potential to be that game-changing pass
rusher for the next few years and you're
still not quite sure let's say like a d4
right where yes there's been injuries
through his career last year he kind of
pops onto the scene i know 2010 he
showed a little glimmer there as well
getting 10 sacks but everything else has
been too few and far between along with
injuries but the pass rushing position
uh and some of these guys that we saw
yesterday yeah these are versatile guys
that can do different things for your
for your defense and this day and age of
multiplicity where offenses can be in a
running set one play in the next set
they're in the shotgun with no back in
the backfield you got to have these type
of players who can make game changing
plays and do different things for your
defense and i think that's what you saw
uh with the franchise tag yesterday
these are all you know four of those
guys uh
are under that category
all right and let's look at at all of
the guys who were tagged yesterday and
let's go ahead and throw robbie gold in
before we throw him back yeah let's get
him in there all due respect to robbie
gold okay which of these guys would you
want both for one year and for the long
term okay uh i i think to me all right
the the ones that jump out to me the the
three there's three here where i go into
that conversation there's two words i
didn't ask for three you watched the one
okay if you asked me for one i'm going
to go with frank clark then right now
frank clark is the guy i look at up in
seattle who is not only a tone setter
for the defense but just like we just
talked about he's a guy that can come
off the edge he can get right in that 10
sacks per year per range
but at the same time he's not just a
pass rusher he can do a lot of different
things he plays the run extremely well
uh he is it seems like he is the leader
of the defense there in seattle making
the comments remember earlier this year
about you know richard sherman's not
here anymore this is my defense now i
mean those are signs of leadership and
he is a difference maker that can do a
lot of different things along the
defensive line and not just off the edge
put your hand down pin your ears back
and rush the passer he could play three
technique defensive tackle and still
hold his own in some of those matchups
too so that would be the one if you made
me pick one
well and here's the thing too i think
he's the one of these guys most likely
to long term deal because i think that
the seahawks realize the significance of
having him around over the long haul and
because they went through that process
last year of clearing out older players
that were consuming a ton of cap space
and this year earl thomas will be gone
they can afford to take a guy like a
frank clark who will make 17.1 million
this year under the franchise tag and
you take that number and you apply a 20
raise that's his tag number next year
that becomes the loose formula for
figuring out how much fully guaranteed
money he gets at signing it's not driven
by the market it's driven by that
franchise tag he'll be looking at about
40 million fully guaranteed over the
first two years they could put a deal
together very fairly quickly to get him
signed long term now here's the reality
july 15 is the deadline it's a deadline
driven business typically that's when
those deals get done but it wouldn't be
all that hard if the seahawks really
want to do it to get a long-term deal
done right now for frank clark and i
think of all those guys he's the one
that should get the long-term deal and
the seahawks should be motivated to do
it chris yeah i'm with you there all the
way i mean he's a guy that is really
just hitting the the peak of his career
as far as you know physical tools and
the mental tools that he's been taught
here the first four or five years in the
nfl now it's all going to come together
to where yeah we're seeing a player in
his prime who can take over certain
moments of the game offenses have to
adjust their game plans when they play a
guy like frank clark and worry about
matchups or who he's who is he against
all of those things but i think it's an
interesting list mike because i think
out of the five guys right we talked
about frank clark gideon county demarcus
lawrence d ford grady jarrett right
those are five difference making
guys on the defensive side of the ball
when i look at that there i go frank
clark demarcus lawrence grady jarrett
those three right there i think are the
most likely to where the teams are gonna
go let's do our best to get a long-term
deal done with these guys we know what
they are as players there hasn't been
much injury history let's try to get
this done now then there's the other two
guys with d ford and gideon clowney
right where i would say this is a one
year prove it to me one more time that
you can stay healthy and be productive d
ford's been injured a lot and kind of
been here and there as far as sac output
gedevian clowney the same thing right
mike i mean we know he had micro
fracture surgery he's had issues with
his knee uh and i would be scared about
giving him anything long-term guaranteed
a lot of lump-sum money right up front i
know that
let's spin it back to demarcus lawrence
i think he gets lost in the shuffle
because there's so many star players in
dallas you got jerry jones who sucks up
a lot of oxygen out of the room for
starters but between dak prescott amari
cooper ezekiel elliott these are all
guys who need to be paid at some point
demarcus lawrence already has been
tagged once that means this year he gets
that 20 bump to 20.56 million and there
are some complications here because even
though he's been healthy he needs
shoulder surgery and he said i'm not
getting the surgery until i get a
long-term deal which is a way to put
pressure on the cowboys to get that
long-term deal because if they wait
until july 15 like they did with dez
bryant when he got his long-term deal
back in 2015 by then you do the surgery
are you going to be ready for the start
of the regular season so there's
pressure on the cowboys to do this and
lawrence has the template that we saw
last year with le'veon bell because even
though no one really knew how this
worked until le'veon bell sat out beyond
the deadline for showing up at all in
2018 everybody now understands that if
florence would sit out the entire season
next year if the cowboys franchise
tagged him again it would be the average
of the five highest-paid quarterbacks
from 2019 based on cap number which
means 26 27 million or more for demarcus
lawrence which means next year he does
what le'veon bell is doing this year
straight to the market so if he's
willing to give up that 20.56 million
and people say well how can you do that
here's how you do it you know there's a
hell of a lot more than 20.56 million
out there right if you can get to the
open market you stay healthy or or you
try to stay healthy you've got the
shoulder injury that you have to deal
with but if you say i'm not playing at
all in 2019 i'm going to the market next
year le'veon bell especially when we see
what le'veon bell gets next week that
could go a long way toward getting guys
like demarcus lawrence to say i'm gonna
sit out a whole year and it used to be
unthinkable but i think it's becoming a
weapon you know we hear so many
complaints about the franchise tag chris
yeah there are weapons for players to
push back and this is one of them in the
second year of the tag sit out the whole
season yeah you're you're right mike i
mean this is really this is one of the
biggest weapons players have this is
really one of the only things they can
really fight back with against this and
that's why i hate it because you know i
can just picture the owners in the
meeting rooms when they're trying to
figure out the cba they they know that
players want to play football that's
what they've done their whole life and
they're betting in in these type of
scenarios with the demarcus lawrence
that at the end of the day he's going to
go gosh i want to be loyal to the guys
in my locker room i want to play with my
friends these are my guys i want to be
there and battle with them uh and i love
playing football and they feel like i
think the owners set this up to where
they thought players would buckle in
these type of situations but what we've
seen and you and i have talked about
this continue this continuing uh growth
on the business side from players and
them handling these situations maybe
with more business savvy than we've ever
seen before where players are aware of
these tools and the things that owners
are doing trying to stop them from
getting long-term
long-term guaranteed money uh so i'm all
for what demarcus lawrence is doing i
love that he's not getting the surgery
first don't get yourself prepared for a
team that's not going to give any
long-term security to you that's for
sure take your time do what's right go
get a second opinion get a third one if
that's you what you want to do but
either way the dallas cowboys need to
find something here because demarcus
lawrence hey he's he is he's one of the
best defensive ends in all of football
he's a difference maker and we know that
defense it relies on that front four
very heavily to carry the load for not
only the defense but the football team
in general
and let's look at look at this bigger
picture and it may be that
the next cba gets done before players
can really demonstrate to the owners how
bad the franchise tag can be for teams
but you know the franchise tag is not
going to go away until the owners want
it to go away and if if and this is
where there's strength in numbers if
every player out there would come
together under the umbrella of the nflpa
and agree
that if i get franchise tagged
none of us are showing up until labor
day weekend like le'veon bell did in
2017. i'm not showing up we're not going
to be around we're going to exercise our
full rights we're not going to sign the
tender now there is a risk they rescind
the tender but if you get everybody on
the same page it's kind of like a mini
strike like all the guys who are
franchise tag come together every year
and say we are not showing up until
every day weekend we are going to
demonstrate that this franchise tag
needs to go that's what you do year one
year two they all agree we're going to
sit out the entire year i mean that's
the way to push back against it and for
the guys who do play year to year look
at what
uh kirk cousins proved look at trumaine
johnson you go year to year under the
tag you get to the third tag you're more
likely to get to the market the more
that players are willing to say i don't
want a long-term deal i want to play
this out i want to take advantage of all
rights i have under the franchise tag
that's the way to demonstrate to the
owners that maybe they need to rethink
this thing maybe there will be some
flaws there that need to be addressed
and i think that the players have far
more power than they realize it's one
thing for media and fans and players to
say the franchise tag stinks it's
another thing to identify key ways you
can turn the tables on the owners with
the franchise tag and i think the
players are starting to figure it out
chris i i do too i mean we you know
it goes back to what i was just saying
the business savvy aspect that the
players are starting to show
i really do like it now hey we talked
about the tool of yeah sure you can sit
out the year if you're in the situation
like demarcus lawrence and do that but
you know on the other side we're
gambling right like kirk cousins did and
trying to maximize two three years in a
row with the franchise tag all that hey
that's risk reward you gotta balance
that out and hey quarterbacks might be
able to do that a little bit more than
some of the other positions in football
especially with the rules right now set
up to where the quarterback can't be hit
like the old days but that's different
than defense to end and that's where i
think they got to be careful just take
it from me a guy who i was never
franchised i was never in that category
but i got tendered and i had just come
off as being the starting quarterback
who led his team to a playoff game and i
probably could have made a stink or held
out for more money that was more uh you
know inclusive as far as to what
starting quarterbacks were making at a
year time but i said you know what i'll
be the good guy i'll just take the
tender i was tendered as a first and
third round draft pick i'll take my
money i believe at the time it was like
2.2 2.3 million dollars and i said i'll
be the good soldier well you know what
happened four weeks later i lose my
spleen i never maximize what i could
have got in that situation and those are
the things you have to worry about if
you do play with the franchise tag you
have to take that risk reward into
account
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports